well the pandemic sparking some interest
in a type of exercise that's helping
people lift their spirits
you've probably heard about it it's
called laughter yoga and during the
seriousness of the pandemic
we could definitely use some of this
right all right the little
look a little wacky in the video but you
know with covered restrictions
instructors around the world
are moving laughter online odette she's
better known as
lady haha and she teaches a class in the
uk
laughter changes the biochemistry within
minutes
we are swamped with endorphins and
serotonin
and happy maker hormones
[Laughter]
okay there is real science to back up
these benefits doctors in california
track the effects of laughter
on the brain and body and research shows
it lowers your blood pressure
it reduces the level of stress hormones
it also helps boost your immune system
and when you're watching these people
just being so gigglish there's something
i tell you are you laughing at me no
there's something
something weird about it like when you
get super super close-ups they're like
all
rocking back and defining so but what
i love is while kirsten's reading about
the laughter she just starts to chuckle